Tu vois ce p'tit stress là ?
C'est bon ça !
*chuchote*
Hé, quand on est en haut, j'veux pas un bruit !
Elle vient dans 3 minutes. Ok ?
Squeezie: Ca va ou quoi ?
Abonné: Oh My God ! (Oh mon dieu)
*Rires*
- Il est là-baas !
- Ça va vieux ?
- Comment tu vas ?
- Mais Squeezie ! *mal prononcé*
*Rires*
- Tu vas bien ?
- Oh c'est pas vrai !
🎵 J'passe mes journées devant un écran,
tout le monde m'dit que c'est indécent 🎵
🎵 Pour se lancer pas besoin d'élan, 🎵
🎵 Seul contre tous, pas grave je me défends 🎵
🎵 7 années sont passées et j'vis d'ma passion 🎵
🎵 J'suis une tête d'affiche de ma génération 🎵
🎵Souvent je me demande si j'mérite vraiment c'qui m'arrive 🎵
🎵 J'suis qu'une personne basique, bon endroit, bon moment 🎵
🎵Shiba dans le salon 🎵 *aboiement*
🎵 Linge sale au pied du lit 🎵
*Ha !*
🎵 Studio, lumière à fond,
pour vidéo pas très ludique, 🎵
*Refrain*
🎵 Tu doutes sur c'que tu fais car tout l'monde te dit d'pas le faire 🎵
🎵 Tu kiffes sur c'que tu fais car personne t'a dit comment faire 🎵
🎵 Concentre-toi sur ton projet, ça plaît déjà à des gens 🎵
🎵 T'as dix commentaires ! 🎵
🎵 Pense à prendre du recul, regarde autour de toi 🎵
🎵 T'es pas tout seul ! 🎵
*Nan nan, nan nan*
*nan*
*Nan nan, nan nan nan*
🎵 Sur mon écran j'fais kiffer des pseudos, des lettres 🎵
🎵 Sur scène j'vois des visages, et des projos, des leds 🎵
🎵 J'reçois plus d'amour qu'un prématuré 🎵
🎵 Même si la télé continue d'm'allumer 🎵
🎵 Le matin j'ai des lettres de fans
🎵 🎵 En soirée j'essaye d'être tenable 🎵
🎵 Des fois j'me sens seul à court d'idées, à tout quitter, jamais j'y penserai 🎵
🎵 J'veux rester un mec simple 🎵
🎵 Et rester dans la vraie vie 🎵
🎵 Braver tous les interdits 🎵
🎵 Eviter l'anesthésie 🎵
*Refrain*
🎵 Tu doutes sur c'que tu fais car tout l'monde te dit d'pas le faire, 🎵
🎵 Tu kiffes sur c'que tu fais car personne t'a dit comment faire 🎵
🎵 Concentre-toi sur ton projet,
ça plait déjà à des gens 🎵
🎵 T'as 10 commentaires 🎵
🎵 Pense à prendre du recul, regarde autour de toi 🎵
🎵 T'es pas tout seul 🎵
*Nan nan, nan nan*
*nan*
*Nan nan, nan*
🎵 Au fond on est tous un peu paumés 🎵
🎵 À chercher quel chemin emprunter 🎵
🎵 Vouloir à tout prix pas décevoir 🎵
🎵 On oublie qu'l'essentiel c'est d'se voir 🎵
🎵 Et au fond on est tous un peu paumés, 🎵
🎵 À chercher quel chemin emprunter, 🎵
🎵 Vouloir à tout prix pas décevoir, 🎵
🎵 On oublie qu'l'essentiel c'est d'se voir ! 🎵
*Refrain*
🎵 Tu doutes sur c'que tu fais car tout l'monde te dit d'pas le faire, 🎵
🎵 Tu kiffes sur c'que tu fais car personne t'as dit comment faire, 🎵
🎵 Concentre-toi sur ton projet,
ça plait déjà à des gens, 🎵
🎵 T'as dix commentaires ! 🎵
🎵 Pense à prendre du recul,
regarde autour de toi 🎵
🎵 T'es pas tout seul ! 🎵
*Nan nan nan nan*
*nan*
Commentateur de foot: *Encouragement*
*Cris*
*Victoire de l'équipe de France 2018 !       *Joie*
🎵 T'es pas tout seul ! 🎵
LES BLEUS SONT CHAMPIONS DU MONDE !!
*Nan nan, nan nan nan*
*Nan nan, nan nan*
🎵 T'es pas tout seul 🎵
🎵 Au fond on est tous un peu paumés 🎵
🎵 À chercher quel chemin emprunter 🎵
🎵 Vouloir à tout prix pas décevoir 🎵
🎵 On oublie qu'l'essentiel c'est d'se voir ! 🎵
*T'es pas tout seul*